Seit vielen jahrzehnten suchen wir menschen nach außerirdischem leben und das auf
Unterschiedlichste art und weise eine idee ist es botschaften ins all zu schicken und mögliche lebewesen dort über unsere
Existenz zu informieren mitte oktober wurde jetzt eine radiowellen botschaften an den planeten g j
273 b gesendet außerirdisches leben dort scheint sehr wahrscheinlich was der inhalt der botschaft war und warum
Außerirdische lebensform wohl schon. Im juni 2000 43 antworten könnten jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Eine botschaft an mögliche außerirdische zu schicken diese idee ist nicht neu wir haben ja hier über die arecibo botschaft berichtet die mitte november
1974 von arecibo
radioteleskop in puerto rico ins all gesendet wurde oder auch die voyager golden record also daten platten mit infos in form von bildern und
Audios die im jahr
1977 an bord von watcher eins und zwei als botschaften an außerirdische lebensform
Im universum adressiert worden waren darauf unter anderem zu entdecken
grußbotschaften den 55 verschiedenen sprachen und musik von wolfgang amadeus mozart
Jetzt bekommen die außerirdischen schon wieder post von der erde die adresse luiten stern ein rotes werkstatt in etwa
12,35 lichtjahren entfernung zu ihm gehören mindestens zwei planeten einer von ihnen geo
273 b ist theoretisch von außerirdischen lebensformen bewohnbar
Abgeschickt wurde die radiowellen botschaft von einem ice kette rada. Im norwegischen troms
initiiert von der organisation meti
international messaging tool extraterrestrial intelligence
In kooperation mit dem sohn a music festival und dem institute of space studies of catalonia und zwar
Im oktober genauer am 16 17 und 18 und zwar dreimal fast die gleiche nachricht inhaltlich
unterscheidet sie sich allerdings stark von den bisherigen nachrichten die aktuellen botschaften haben laut einem interview von space.com mit dem medi
präsidenten das war koch nicht in anspruch
Enzyklopädisch zu sein stattdessen hat man sich auf mathematische und wissenschaftliche inhalte konzentriert
Da glaswerk koch sagt weiter meine befürchtung ist dass wenn man versucht alles zu kommunizieren ob man
Am ende gar nichts sagt und so müssen die potenziellen außerirdischen empfänger sich mit unserer idee von mathematik herumschlagen
Denn die nachricht beginnt mit einer demonstration wie wir zählen dann folgen die grundrechenarten so wie beispielsweise der satz des pythagoras
Die nachricht erklärt außerdem auch noch die speziellen wellen aus denen sie besteht und das alles sollte nicht
Zu viel verlangt sein wenn die außerirdischen es ebenso wie wir
geschafft haben sollten ein radioteleskop zu bauen dann wird die nachricht an georg 273 b aber auch noch richtig
Denn dann gibt es neben dem komplizierten mathematischen berechnungen noch musik und außerdem eine art deadline denn die botschaft
verrät
Den potenziellen außerirdischen lebensform auch wann sie uns am besten fall
Antworten sollen nämlich dann wenn wir hinhören und zwar am 21 juni
2043 dann also könnten wir also post von geo
273 bekommen und natürlich gibt es auch hier kritiker wie schon immer seitdem wir versuchen mit außerirdischen lebensform kontakt aufzunehmen einige
befürchten eine invasion von höher entwickelten lebewesen die wir durch solche nachrichten auf den plan gerufen haben die unsere existenz
also vorher gar nicht auf dem schirm hatten physiker stephen
Hawking ist da zum beispiel einer der kritiker dass bei koch hält das aber für unsinn es fällt mir wirklich schwer mir ein szenario
auszumalen in dem eine zivilisation rund um den nöten stern zwar die fähigkeit entwickelt haben könnten zur erde zu gelangen und uns zu bedrohen
dennoch nicht schon längst unseren bisherigen unfreiwilligen tv
Radiosignale empfang als solche erkannt haben könnte mit. I will also weitermachen zum einen will die organisation
botschaften auch an andere sterne verschicken und zum anderen soll auch geo
273 b noch einmal kontaktiert werden eine zweite nachricht soll
Im april gesendet werden sie soll erklären wie wir menschen musik verstehen
außerirdische sind ja hier bei pixum immer wieder ein thema wenn ihr kein video dazu verpassen wollt dann sollten wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann verpasst ja auch kein video hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken aliens der erste kontakt
sehr interessant ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran